all the left and the media attack dogs
can dish it out can't they but they sure
can't take it last night we played clips
of NBA superstars LeBron James Kevin
Durant and an ESPN co-host named Carrie
champion trashing Trump the number one
job in America the point of person is
someone who doesn't understand the
people and really don't get by the
people I feel like our team as a as a
country is not ran by a great coach it's
not even a surprise when he says
something it's not even surprised like
laughable it's like but it's also scary
shouldn't be numb to your racist right
right I shouldn't be numb to your
behavior I called those remarks barely
intelligible
not to mention ungrammatical and last
night which is difficult to dispute and
the left erupted Slate's piece was
titled and insulting LeBron James Laura
Ingraham proves James point about racism
okay it accused me of quote something
vile and racist almost all the stories
accused me of dog whistle commentary and
many claim my line that LeBron should
shut up and dribble was racist uh what I
wrote a book fifteen years ago fairly
well-known New York Times bestseller
called
shut up and sing and I've been using
variants of that title to call out
political celebrities for 15 years
without regard for skin color where you
came from what you do by the way
including on this show without a single
fact on your side well Jamie all I can
say is you're far from perfect oh
remember that movie with John Travolta
now I might not look to her for
political analysis but I am if I'm
looking for a great pair of leg warmers
I'm calling her first Hamill has been
hammering president Trump on Twitter for
months and now feels qualified to weigh
in on net neutrality because of his long
distinguished career on screen in films
such as Star Wars and Star Wars sequels
Kimmel's a millionaire who doesn't need
chip or any other program provide health
care for his beautiful child shut up and
sing or shut up an axe or shut up and
make us laugh every now and then so I'm
an equal-opportunity Critic when it
comes to left-wing celebrity sounding
off on topics of which they know
precious little and as you can see race
has nothing to do with it joining me now
to discuss our Nyjah Rena sone lean on
me for 20-something years national
spokesperson for the Congress of racial
equality and Burgess Owens a retired NFL
star good to have you both on
all right Burgess you can take it away
you know these guys are big guys they're
incredibly talented on the court but boy
they can dish it out to trump use the
f-bomb you know call him you know all
sorts of names say he doesn't care about
people all this stuff but when I call
them out for their insipid commentary
they immediately throw down the race
card well this is Laura this is a new
norm for the left when white
conservative calls of black liberal
clueless
they're called racist if white liberals
call a black conservative Uncle Tom
they're called enlightened this is what
these people do they're bullies they
don't want to talk about topics and I'll
say this the problem we're having now is
we have too many quote leaders that are
going from poor to wealthy going to
becoming elitist and skipping through
what's called middle class middle class
is where you find empathy service and
understanding and relationship and we're
missing that so all of a sudden easily
TISS overcoming our leaders as if they
know everything and they don't so we
have to put that in perspective and
realize that these are athletes these
are entertainers and and look at them as
entertainers and nothing more they're
not experts anything else but but
dribbling and singing and running a
football that's it Niger this was LeBron
James at the it was just you know epic
2016 championship parade Cleveland
finally wins the championship it was a
big deal he was having fun there's a lot
of families there let's watch like I'm
gonna wake up and it's gonna be like
Game four all over again I'm like be
down to one still
LeBron James makes six straight Finals
appearances when James Jones made six
straight as well you had to be our
anchor in the interior and you looked at
me like man you don't know me should I
love all y'all and get ready for next
year is that what addicted to the F I
was a couple f5s bomb and you know he
was having fun but yeah come on okay
it's just like a clown I mean he's done
a lot of good stuff yeah like a lot of
good charity work what if you're gonna
talk like that you're gonna act like
that and you talk like that about the
president United States I tell you
something if you're a white NBA player
and he said that stuff that he said
about Obama
you'd never play again oh no question
about it I think he called the president
of United States a bum yeah you know and
used the f-bomb and describing him and
that that ESPN podcast as well Kevin
Durant said the comment shut up and
dribble is racist oh my goodness well
you know alright sensitive well here it
is that the tale of the tape we've got
Kevin Durant about seven foot one or
something like that index nine we got
Laura Ingraham here at five foot six
five foot seven something like that -
seven what heels me thank you hey and
he's running away from you I mean that
you know for guys that winning NBA
championships and and and had that much
kind of that kind of stature it's a
little down the race card look this is
my point
verges if you want to be a political
pundit you're coming on my court okay be
let's let's do it let's let's have a
real conversation about black
unemployment let's have to talk about
violence in the inner-city let's talk
about all the issues like school choice
and let's do it let's have don't don't
think you're not gonna get criticized if
all you do is a drive-by hit on Trump
and say he's no he's no later leader you
know you know he's a bomb if you're
gonna do it then do it let's have a real
conversation yeah that's the thing
they're not gonna have a real
conversation lower because it takes
thinking it takes really trying to
figure out the answers actually iris
purses I might not agree with everything
was Charles Barkley I'm not sure I have
a lot of respect for that guy though cuz
he he shown me that he cares more about
his race
and politics more about his race in
popular and these these other guys these
elitist exactly --ts they have to deal
through a world and I'll be honest with
you I'll be on I came out NFL tenure
after ten years a flaming liberal
antidote to that was taking my cocky
liberal attitude start a business
failing the end of my needs a bunch of
times realize I don't want to be liberal
and I definitely want to be cocky
anymore that's what these guys end up
having they're doing to me while we need
to find free enterprises let's make our
heroes entrepreneurs those that get out
and take a risk serve and find an answer
trial solutions not these athletes whose
know how to run and throw a football and
we're gonna dribble a basketball like
that that has no real value to the real
world into our black community so let's
find a real deal true entrepreneurs by
the way LeBron I guess you call him King
James he put out a full screen response
I guess kind of a response which is kind
of cute it says smiling through it all
can't believe this my life alright I
guess who needs verbs there's a serious
point here though I mean these these men
are black men at a time that black men
are going through it seems like the
economic revival during the Trump is
great with jobs economic opportunity the
absolute worst thing for Kevin Durant to
do is play a multi-million dollar victim
to poor Laura to it's a big bad Laura
Ingraham you are scary Laura well some
of the responses on Twitter today this
is always this is always fun Ellen
Pompeo she's on the I guess she was on
Grey's Anatomy is that still on the air
I don't know sorry someone tell this be
to meet me outside oh I'm so not in the
mood for playing nice or polite this
week apparently she was nice and polite
other weeks I mean there was so many of
them you can't read but their Knesset is
real quick one of the things that I
can't guarantee these people have no
idea about what's happening we're not in
our communities a day they have no idea
that the unemployment rate is going down
that people are getting jobs and
education being checked they have no
idea because they're listening to these
other Marxist and socialists that don't
want to divide it when our race to
understand the truth so we have to
realize the truth is coming through by
people living their lives and and and
it's been succeeding and I'm looking
forward to seeing more right great well
we had that Kehinde Wiley you did the
portrait of Obama holding up the the
african-american depictions holding up
white women decapitated and said it was
it's sort of a play on the kill whitey
thing no criticism there though
guys great to have you on thanks so much
and thank you we'll continue this I'm
sure next week I don't things gonna die
down